avant de commencer j'aimerais vous poser
une question êtes vous heureux dans
votre
vie alors vous
doute c'est souvent compliqué j'ai des
contraintes et des problèmes mais
j'essaye dès que je peux de faire tout
pour l'être car sans doute le but de la
vie pour tout être humain c'est de
chercher et d'essayer d'être heureux et
bien le problème est que pour nous
rendre heureux
à l'ère digitale notre cerveau se
tromper sans que nous en ayons
conscience aujourd'hui la première
activité des êtres humains ça consiste à
regarder des écrans par exemple notre
cerveau nous incite souvent à passer du
temps sur notre mobile alors vous allez
me dire c'est normal ça me plaît gm être
par exemple sur les réseaux sociaux
je vais vous expliquer comment de
récentes recherches scientifiques nous
apprennent à se méfier des illusions de
bonheur avec les écrans et ces mêmes
recherches scientifiques peuvent de
l'autre côté nous aider à accroître
notre bien-être avec notre smartphone et
plus généralement avec les écrans alors
tout d'abord la première illusion de
bonheur concerne les réseaux sociaux de
nombreuses recherches scientifiques ont
démontré que plus on passe du temps sur
les réseaux sociaux et plus ça altère
notre bien-être c'est à dire plus on
développe des troubles dépressifs et des
troubles anxieux d'ailleurs les
adolescents et les jeunes adultes qui
vont sur les réseaux sociaux au delà de
deux heures par jour ont une probabilité
plus forte d'avoir une mauvaise santé
mentale est également une plus faible
estime de soi alors récemment en plus de
la durée les chercheurs ont mis en
lumière un phénomène surprenant selon
que nous utilisons les réseaux sociaux
soit de manière active soit de manière
passive
notre morale peut soit s'améliorer soit
se dégrader sans même que nous en ayons
conscience à leur actif
ça signifie que nous privilégions les
réseaux sociaux et les activités qui
permettent de communiquer avec les
autres et de poster par exemple des
messages
alors ça c'est plutôt bon pour le bien
être une utilisation passive ça signifie
que nous allons consommer des
informations mais sans communiqué on va
regarder les messages des autres on lit
les tweets les story mais sans y réagir
alors c'est là que les problèmes
psychologiques naissent les
scientifiques ont essayé de comprendre
pourquoi et avec
calé nouvelles recherches nous avons de
réponse première raison c'est lorsque
nous regardons les postes ou story des
autres sans en avoir conscience
nous nous comparons on se compare à leur
vie et comme chaque personne pose des
messages ou des photos qui les
valorisent ce qui les regarde pense
souvent que la vie de ceux qui les
postes est génial et que donc par
contraste la leur et donc moins
intéressante à la fois nous sommes un
peu jaloux quelque part de la vie
apparemment superbe des autres et à la
fois nous trouvons notre propre vie
terne
donc notre cerveau compare notre vie à
la vie des autres montré dans ses photos
résultat là pour ceux qui le font
souvent ça peut conduire à force à des
troubles dépressifs
il ya une deuxième raison c'est que
notre cerveau nous incite à fréquenter
très souvent les réseaux sociaux à cause
d'une anxiété qui s'appelle la fomo fear
of missing out c'est à dire une crainte
que les autres s'amusent sans que nous
en ayons conscience et nous sommes
quelque part exclu de l'expérience
intéressante des autres les autres ont
des expériences et pas nous et beaucoup
de personnes qui vont sur les réseaux
sociaux ont cette forme ont surtout
celles qui vont beaucoup et qui sont
parfois dépendant des réseaux sociaux
alors la dépendance est d'ailleurs plus
fréquente chez les filles que chez les
garçons mais c'est pas encore une
addiction qui est officiellement reconnu
les garçons quant à eux ils sont plus
souvent addict aux jeux vidéo alors ça
c'est une maladie mentale qui est
quasiment reconnue comme une addiction
par les médecins et les psychologues
pour le prouver
j'ai effectué au sein de mon laboratoire
de recherche
une étude scientifique sur une
population de france est confiné dans
leur domicile à cause de lakovic 19 en
2020 et nous résultats montrent que les
français interrogés ont fortement
utilisé les réseaux sociaux de manière
passive et ça leur a posé aucun problème
psychologique
alors vous allez me dire que c'est
contraire à ce que je viens de vous dire
bien non parce que en cours de
confinement nous étions sûrs que ceux
avec qui nous étions en relation sur les
sociaux n'avait pas une vie plus
marrante que la nôtre que les autres ne
faisait pas plus de soirées ou de voyage
merveilleux que nous donc il n'y a pas
eu de problèmes psychologiques néfastes
allait fortement sur les réseaux sociaux
nos résultats montrent que cependant en
période hors confinement c'est la
comparaison avec les autres et parfois
jalousie ainsi que la peur qu'on ne vive
pas les mêmes moments heureux que les
autres qui globalement nous rend
malheureux on a une deuxième illusion de
bonheur avec les écrans le matérialisme
plusieurs études sont en effet arrivés à
la conclusion selon laquelle plus on est
matérialiste et moins on est heureux
le matérialisme c'est généralement
défini comme le fait de vouloir posséder
des biens des produits des marques et le
fait de penser que c'est bien et ces
produits peuvent nous rendre heureux
alors du coup c'est un cercle vicieux
parce que le matérialisme va diminuer le
bonheur et moins on est heureux plus on
veut acheter des produits et des marques
pour compenser et plus on est déçus et
donc plus on va en racheter d'autres etc
et ce problème commence relativement tôt
chez les enfants entre 8 et 11 ans les
jeunes les plus insatisfaits à l'égard
de leur vie devienne dès cet âge
relativement matérialiste les moins
heureux vont donc essayer de compenser
leur insatisfaction en cherchant à
posséder des produits mais cet effet ne
fonctionne que pour les enfants qui sont
fréquemment exposés la publicité
notamment la télévision quand on regarde
la plupart des contenus qui sont
véhiculées dans les médias notamment la
publicité et globalement ça joue un rôle
relativement négatif dans la mesure où
les publicités notamment font croire
qu'on est heureux quand on possède des
produits et des marques soit il apporte
du plaisir immédiat soit ils sont
utilisés par des gens célèbres
extrêmement attirant comme s'ils
constituaient le sorte de récompense et
de preuve de réussite sociale
d'ailleurs les enfants de milieux
défavorisés pose davantage qu'il est
important d'acquérir des marques connues
notamment qui ont un prix élevé
que les enfants des milieux favorisés
c'est donc bien ici une illusion est un
des problèmes c'est que les enfants
n'ont pas la maturité intellectuelle
pour lutter contre les techniques
persuasive utilisés dans les publicités
par exemple pour les publicités pour des
produits trop gras ou trop sucrés comme
des gâteaux et des boissons sucrées par
exemple ce type de publicité provoque
c'était démontré une augmentation du
grignotage et du surpoids on peut pas
dire que ça se soit le bonheur alors les
effets non conscient de la publicité
sont tellement forts qui joue également
sur les adultes notre cerveau nous
bernent ans nous influence en à notre
insu je vous citerai quelques recherches
que j'ai menée dans mon laboratoire
scientifique notamment dans une première
expérimentation nous avons montré que
lorsque nous entre apercevons très vite
une publicité sur internet et que nous
n'oubliions aussitôt parce que en
général on fait autre chose sur internet
et que d'une façon générale les pubs ne
nous intéresse pas et bien notre mémoire
memories tout de même à notre insu cette
marque
et si jamais nous l'art voyons trois
mois plus tard nous allons l'apprécié
toujours davantage sans même savoir
pourquoi
dans une autre expérimentation que nous
avons réalisé ce coup ci avec une caméra
qui va enregistrer ce que regard nos
yeux nous avons montré que lorsque des
bannières publicitaires sur internet
pour une marque par exemple apparaissent
en haut d'un écran alors que nous on
regarde au centre de l'écran et donc on
ne voit absolument pas les publicités et
de manière consciente puisque on regarde
le centre de l'écran est bien notre
cerveau les perçoit tout de même et les
mémorise à notre insu et une semaine
après notre cerveau s'en souvient encore
et il va davantage apprécié la marque
qui était dans la publicité sans même
que nous en ayons conscience et sans
aucun souvenir des publicités alors ça
c'est pour les adultes mais nous avons
mené également une autre expérimentation
auprès d'enfants et nous avons montré
que ces effets non conscient fonctionne
aussi sur les enfants aient les
préadolescents qui sort sur internet par
exemple
ces enfants et ces adolescents aiment
davantage la marque
une semaine après
alors qu'ils ne se souviennent
absolument pas d'avoir vu les publicités
ces problématiques
je vais vous donner une petite technique
pour lutter contre certains de ses
effets non conscient de la publicité au
moment de l'achat si vous achetez sans
trop réfléchir
votre cerveau va vous inciter à acheter
les marques dont vous avez vu les pubs
mais vous atténuer les effets si vous
vous donnez des règles précises et
consciente d'achat par exemple je prends
le meilleur rapport qualité prix
ou alors j'achète les produits qui sont
les plus respectueux de l'environnement
ou les meilleurs pour la santé
voilà donc une technique avoir
clairement en tête des règles au moment
d'acheter
alors maintenant
quittons ce monde d'illusions qu'est ce
que le vrai bonheur avec les écrans
qu'est ce que le vrai bonheur à l'ère
digitale le bonheur le plus profond on
l'a vu c'est pas le bonheur avec les
biens matériels
c'est pas la recherche de plaisirs
immédiats mais c'est un bonheur qui est
atteint à plus long terme
lorsqu'on a le sentiment qu'on améliore
toujours plus ses qualités morales c'est
force de caractère et qu'on donne un
plus grand sens à sa vie dans le sens de
ces valeurs en respectant ses valeurs
c'est ce qu'on appelle le bonheur ed
monique alors la bonne nouvelle c'est
que les écrans peuvent aussi contribuer
à améliorer ce bien-être ce bonheur ed
monique alors vous comprendrez bien que
je partage pas l'idée qu'on entend
souvent aujourd'hui et qui consiste à
critiquer parfois fortement des écrans
on a des recherches scientifiques qui
montrent aussi le côté positif des
écrans d'ailleurs on en a parlé dans un
livre au titre évocateur qui s'appelle
connectés et heureux et dans ce livre on
montre qu'on peut par exemple accroître
son bien être des monique avec des bons
films ou avec des bonnes séries en
parlant de ça vous ne vous êtes pas
rendu compte que ces dernières années
dans les séries il y à une évolution
d'image d'euros on ne les montre plus
comme avant comme des personnes qui
avaient surtout des qualités
moi je me souviens quand j'étais plus
jeune j'étais fan de séries comme les
mystères de l'ouest amicalement vôtre
drôles de dames starsky et hutch et les
héros n'avait quasiment que des côtés
positifs
aujourd'hui on les montre comme des
personnes qui ont également un côté
sombre the walking dead la casa des
papes elle breaking bad
lucifer dexter par exemple selon vous
pour quelles raisons aime ton ce type de
film et bien parce qu'il nous permet de
nous questionner sur ce qu'est le bien
et le mal sur nos propres valeurs et de
les remettre en question et de cette
manière on va s'améliorer
on apprend des choses sur soi sur les
autres sur la vie et ça c'est une
composante du bonheur ed monique bien
plus forte pour accroître notre bonheur
que le matérialisme que le fait de
vouloir posséder des produits par
exemple
alors finalement à l'ère digitale ce que
disaient les philosophes grecs à
l'époque de l'antiquité est parfaitement
juste chercher à s'améliorer à diminuer
certains cds faut accroître ses qualités
à sentir qu'on y parvient dans notre cas
inciter par des héros de film ça ça peut
être intéressant et donc beaucoup de
séries télé contribuer à ça elle donne
l'opportunité de davantage réfléchir sur
soi même sur le sens de la vie à la
condition vous l'aurez compris qu'on se
pose les bonnes questions en les
regardant d'une manière un peu
différente que ce qu'on fait
habituellement je vais vous donner un
autre exemple pourquoi aime-t-on selon
vous les films dramatiques ou triste
c'est paradoxal on aime parfois les
films où on a pleuré
eh bien on a aussi des recherches
scientifiques sur ce point en fait ils
permettent d'apprendre des choses sur sa
propre vie et d'être plus fort alors
d'abord ils montrent des personnes qui
sont malheureuses et en nous comparant à
elle par contraste ça augmente notre
bonheur mais surtout ils nous apprennent
à rebondir face à un problème a réagi
reçoit même face à des difficultés
ils permettent de nous questionner et de
questionner la vie sas à accroître notre
capacité de réfléchir surtout quand nous
discutons du film ensuite avec les
autres en échange on apprend par les
autres grâce au film qu'est ce que tu
aurais fait dans ce cas là bas moi
j'aurais plutôt faire on discute et des
recherches récentes montrent qu'on
apprend parfois autant en regardant un
film que dans la vraie vie on apprend
par exemple à maîtriser ses peurs à
trouver des solutions aux grands
problèmes de la vie alors dans l'étude
que nous avons réalisés sur les français
en confinement au cours de l'épidémie de
covin 19
de nombreuses personnes nous ont dit
avoir regardé des films mettant en scène
des catastrophes épidémique com
virus ou contagion par exemple leurs a
priori on pourrait dire c'est un peu fou
parce que on parle du virus toute la
journée et en plus certains regardent
des films d'épidémie le soir eh bien ça
leur a permis de donner du sens à ce
qu'elle vivait et quelque part être plus
forts alors en conclusion s'il ya le
message à donner pour ne pas se faire
prendre aux illusions du bonheur à l'ère
digitale
c'est d'avoir une vraie intelligence
numérique c'est à dire ne pas trop se
dire que les autres ont une meilleure
vie que la sienne notamment sur les
réseaux sociaux ne pas penser que le
bonheur est dans le matérialisme où la
publicité mais ça consiste à donner du
sens à sa vie
sur le long terme et pour ça il faut pas
hésiter à regarder des bons films ou des
bonnes séries télé mais allez regarder
un peu différemment et ça ça va nous
aider à nous poser les bonnes questions
sur nos propres valeurs sur le sens de
la vie et même plus généralement sur la
société
merci de votre attention